Thanks for having me.
I listened to you on Sam Harris'
podcast and I was utterly stunned.
I had to listen to it twice cause I just
couldn't believe it. Let's get into,
let's get into this from the beginning.
How did this start out?
How did you start researching these,
a online Russian trolls
and bots and all this jazz?
Yeah, so a couple of years
back in around 2015, um, I,
I had had my first baby in 2013 and I
was getting on these preschool lists.
And what I decided to do was
I started looking at, um,
anti vaccine activity in California
because I had a kid and I wanted to, uh,
you know,
put them on preschool lists or I was going
to fit with the parents basically. Um,
as someone who vaccinates and I started
looking at the way that small groups,
we're able to kind of disproportionately
amplify messages on social channels.
And some of this was through
very legitimate activity.
And then some of it was through really
kind of coordinated deliberate attempts
to kind of game, um, ways that
algorithms were amplifying content,
amplifying particular types of narratives.
And I thought it was interesting and
I started writing about it and I, um,
I wound up writing about ways in
which, um, hashtag gaming, um,
ways in which people were kind of using
automation to just be in a Hashtag all
the time.
So it was kind of a way to really gain
control of share voice and what that
meant when very small groups of people
could achieve this kind of phenomenal
amplification and what the pros and cons
of that were. And then this was, um,
2015. So the way that,
that this sort of, um,
awareness of social media challenges came,
came about was actually
when I was working on this.
Other people were looking at it from the
same, um, looking at the same tactics,
but how they were being used by Isis,
by the terrorist organization.
And they're also,
you had this very small group of
people that manage to use bots and
amplification to really kind of own
a narrative, really pushed this,
this brand is this digital caliphate to
kind of build it on all social platforms
almost simultaneously.
And the ways in which information was
hopping from one platform to another, um,
through kind of deliberate coordination
and then also just ways in which
information flows, kind
of contagion style. Um,
and I wound up working on thinking about
how the government was going to respond
to the challenge of
terrorist organizations using
American social platforms to
spread propaganda.
Uh,
so what we came to realize was that
there was just this information ecosystem
and it had evolved in a certain way over
a period of about eight years or so.
And the kind of unintended consequences
of that and the way that Russia kind of,
uh, came into the conversation
was around October,
2015 when we were thinking about what,
what to do about Isis,
what to do about terrorism
and terrorist, uh, you know,
kind of proliferation on social platforms.
This was right around when Adrian
Chen had written the article,
the Agency for the New York Times.
And that was one of the first big expos
A's of the Internet research agency.
The first time an American journalist
had gone over there and actually met the
trolls,
been in Saint Petersburg and began write
about what was happening over there and
the ways that they had pages that we're
targeting certain facets of American
culture.
So while we were in DC talking about
what to do about terrorists using these
platforms to spread propaganda,
there were beginning to be rumblings
that Russian intelligence and you know,
Russian entities,
we're doing the same thing.
And so the question became can we think
about ways in which the Internet is
vulnerable to this type of
manipulation by anyone? And then, um,
and then come up with ways to stop it.
So that was how the Russia
investigation began,
was actually around 2015 and a handful
of people started looking for evidence of
Russian bots and trolls
on social platforms.
So 2015 if we think about social
media and the birth of social media,
essentially, it had only been alive
for, I mean, what was Twitter,
2007 I believe. Think so, yeah,
something like that. So eight years,
like eight years of social media.
And then all the sudden they figured
out how to game the system and then they
figured out how to use this to make
people argue against each other.
Yeah, I think so. There was
this, if you go back to like, um,
I remember like Geo cities
and they all use that. Um,
so we're probably about the same age.
Um, so there have always been, you know,
kind of the thing thing that was great
about the Internet, like Internet 1.0,
we can call it right,
was this idea that everybody was given
a platform and you could use your
platform, you could put up your blog,
you could say whatever you wanted. Um,
you didn't necessarily get attention,
but you could say whatever you wanted.
And so there is this
kind of consolidation as,
as social platforms kind of came
into existence, content creators.
We're really excited about the fact
that now they not only had this, um,
this access to write their own stuff,
but they also had access to this audience
because as the network effects got
more and more pronounced, more and more
people came to be on social platforms.
And in originally it wasn't even Facebook.
If I remember, it was like, you know,
there's like Friendster and myspace
and social networks kind of evolved.
When I was in college, Facebook was
still limited to like, you know,
a handful of like Ivy League schools.
And so I wasn't even eligible.
And as you watch this
consolidation happen,
you start to have this information
ecosystem really dominated by a handful of
companies that grow very large because
they're providing a service that people
really want.
Um,
but there's a kind of mass consolidation
of audiences onto this handful of
platforms.
So this becomes really interesting for
regular people who just want to find
their friends, reach people, spread
their message, growing audience.
It also becomes really interesting for
propagandists and trolls and in this case
terrorist organizations and
state intelligence services.
Cause instead of reaching
the entire Internet,
they really just kind of have to
concentrate their efforts on a handful of
platforms.
So that consolidation is one of the
things that kind of kicks off some of the,
um, one of one of the reasons
that we have these problems today,
right? So the, the fact that there's
only a Facebook, a Twitter and,
and a couple other minor
platforms other than Youtube,
I mean anything that you can tell
it's an actual person like youtube,
that is a problem, right? Because
you could see it's an actual person.
If you're of, you're narrating
something, you, you know,
if you're in front of the camera and
explaining things and people who going to
know that you're an actual human being.
Whereas there's so many of these
accounts that I'll go to, like I'll,
I'll watch people get involved in these
little online beefs with each other and
then I'll go to some of these accounts.
I'm like,
this doesn't seem like a real person.
And I'll go and it's like Hashtag Magda,
there's a American Eagle in front of a
flag and then you read their stuff and
you're like, wow, this is, this is
probably a Russian troll account.
And it's strange, like you feel like
you're not supposed to be seeing this.
Like you've seen the wiring under the
board or something and then you'll go
through the timeline and all they're
doing is engaging people and arguing,
you know, for Trump and against, you know,
whatever the fuck they're angry about,
whatever,
whatever it is that's being discussed.
And they're,
they're basically just like some
weird little argument mechanism.
Yeah. So in 2016, um,
there was a lot of that during
the presidential campaign,
right. And there were,
um, there was so much that
was written, you know,
we can go back to the free speech thing
we were kind of chatting about before.
There was so much that was written about
harassment and trolling and negativity
and these kind of hoards of accounts that
would brigade people and harass them.
Of course, a lot of that is
just real Americans, right?
There are plenty of people who are just
assholes on the Internet. Sure. Um,
but there were actually a fair
number of these as we began to do the
investigation into the
Russian operation in, uh,
it started on Twitter and about,
um, 2014, actually, so 2013, 2014,
the Internet research agency
is targeting Russian people.
So they're tweeting in Russian, at
Russian and Ukrainian, uh, folks,
people in their sphere of influence.
So they're already on there.
They're already trying this out.
And what they're doing is they're
creating these are these, these accounts,
it's kind of wrong to call them
bots because they are real people.
They're just not what they appear to be.
So I think the unfortunate term
for it has become like Cyborg,
like semi automated. You know,
sometimes it's automated,
sometimes it's a real person,
but a sock puppet is the other
way that we can refer to it.
A person pretending to be somebody else.
So you have these sock puppets and
they're out there and they're tweeting.
And in 2014 about the Russian
annexation of Crimea or about mh 17.
That plane that went down with Russia,
you know,
of course I had no idea what happened
and it wasn't their fault at all.
And gradually as they begin to experience
what I imagine they thought of what
success, that's when you see some of these
accounts pivot to targeting Americans.
And so in 20, late 2014, early
2015, you start to see the,
um, the strategy that for a long
time had been very inwardly focused,
making their own people think a certain
way or feel a certain way or have a
certain experience on the Internet. Uh,
it begins to spread out. It begins to, uh,
to look. And so you start to see these
accounts communicating with Americans.
And as we were going through the datasets,
which the Twitter data set is public,
anyone can go and look
at it at this point. Um,
you do see some of the accounts that
are kind of, um, you know, that were,
that were somewhat notorious for
being really virulent, nasty trolls.
I'm antisemitic trolls going
after journalists. You know,
some of these accounts,
um,
being revealed as actually being a
Russian trolls now it doesn't kind of, um,
exculpate the actual American trolls
that were very much real and active and
part of this and expressing their opinion.
But you do see that
they're mimicking this.
They're using that same style of tactic,
that harassment to,
to get it real people.
Then if they do get banned,
if their account gets banned,
they just simply make another
account. They use some sort of, uh,
you know, um, what is it,
a virtual virtual server,
what does that call mean? Vpns are,
that's, yeah, so if they do that,
they can kind of do that
as long as they want.
They can continue to make new accounts
and it probably also emboldens the actual
American trolls because they're going
to go out a little bit further than
everybody else.
A little bit crazier.
And it kind of changes the
tone of discourse within
these communities that are
arguing about a certain subject.
Things get nastier and they're getting
nastier because of the interference of
these trolls. Like, it seems like they've,
they've actually managed to not
just cause a lot of discourse,
but to change the way people
are interacting with each
other and to make it just
make it more,
more vicious.
Yeah. So the, what they're doing is
they're operating in communities.
So one of the really common criticisms
of, you know, people who, um,
lot of people think that this
didn't have a huge impact. You know,
did it swing the election?
We have no idea. Um, but the,
what it does do in the communities that
it targets is it can change that tone.
And that's where you see,
um, it's, it's, I mean,
think everybody's probably
had this experience,
you're part of a group and then a new
person gets added to the group and the
dynamic changes.
It's very much the same kind of thing,
just that these are not real people
who are joining the group. Uh,
and so there's this,
um, opportunity to, to,
to,
you know,
kind of expand the balance of tolerance
just that little bit more or try to
normalize using particular ways of
communicating that maybe a group wouldn't
naturally gravitate to.
But then it does. So there,
there are definitely a ways in which any,
any type of troll doing this
doesn't have to be a Russian troll,
has this ability to kind of shift
the language of the community,
shifts the culture just a little bit.
Now, when did, why did the agency
do this and do we do we know,
do we have someone who's ever left there
or become a whistle blower who can give
us some information about what the
mandate was and how it was carried out?
There've been a couple of a whistle and
actually some investigative journalism
in Russia that's, that's covered
this. Um, they describe the,
the employees of these as
the Internet research agency.
So it's a little bit like a social
media marketing agency plus, um,
tactics that we would not expect a
social media marketing agency to use.
Things that are a little more like
what you would expect to see from an
intelligence agency.
So besides just making your pages
in your blogs and your social posts,
they're also in their kind of,
uh,
connecting with real people and real
activists and pretending to be something
that they're not to develop kind of a
one on one relationship, but most of the,
most of the, um, the whistle
blowers who have come out,
there's a woman named
Ludmila savage, chuck. Um,
she wrote an expos I believe on this.
And it's described as being much like
you would expect if you were doing social
media grunt work. Um, you have a certain
number of posts per day. You, you know,
you're driving, trying to get a certain
amount of engagement. Um, you're trying,
you've got to kind of hit your quotas.
Most people are young millennials,
the people that work there, um, they're
well versed in trolling culture.
They're well versed in internet culture.
You know,
they're up to speed on like
popular memes and things like that.
And so you do see, um, this, yeah.
And then the other thing that they do is
they talk about in Mueller indictment,
you see some really interesting
descriptions of like the
standups that they have
stand up as a thing you
do at a tech company.
Everybody kind of stands
up and talk about your, uh,
goals and responsibilities
and blockers and things.
And in the standups they would be
sitting there saying things like, um,
if you're targeting black LGBT people,
make sure you don't use
white people in your,
in your image and your mean because that's
going to trigger them. Um, you know,
so trying to get at
the, the very niche, um,
rules for, you know, for communicating
authentically and an American community,
which is, you know, online,
you know, you sometimes, um,
there are very specific ways in which
a community expects a member of that
community to communicate.
And so they are in there and you can read
in these filings by Mueller's team and
by the Eastern District
of Virginia. Um, the, the,
the degree of granularity that they have
to recognize that if you are running a
black LGBT page and your
meme is of white people,
you're going to cause some tension and
consternation and assuming that that's
not necessarily what you want to be doing,
you should go find the meme of black
LGBT people to put in the, you know, to,
to put as your meme for the
day. So there's a lot of, um,
there's a lot of sophistication,
there's a lot of understanding of
American culture and then there's a lot of
understanding of trolling culture.
And so these things combined to be
a rather effective, uh, you know,
very effective social media agency.
Then is there an overwhelming sort of
narrative that they're trying to pursue?
The trying to push. So what
we saw, so I did the, um,
I did some of the research for the
Senate and the Senate data came from the
platforms. So what I had was, um, the
attribution was made by the platforms.
It wasn't like Renee deciding this was
IRA. It was, uh, the giving it to, uh,
to our government and the
information in there.
Um,
what it showed was that
across all platforms, across
Twitter, across Facebook,
Instagram, youtube, they
were building up tribes.
So they were really working to create
distinct communities of distinct types of
Americans. And that would be, for example,
there's an LGBT page that is very
much about LGBT pride. There is, uh,
created it and they created it. And
Dave, they curate it and they create it,
curate it. Um, it has a, you
know, they're just like a persona.
A lot of the posts on the LGBT page were
written by what sounded kind of like a
millennial lesbian was the voice.
Um, so it was a lot of, um, you know,
memes of LGBT actresses and they
would brand it with a specific brand.
Market was a rainbow heart. Um, uh,
LGBT United was the name of the page.
It had a matching Instagram account,
which you would also expect to
see from a media property. Right?
You would expect them to see in
both places. And this, um, you know,
it read like a, or like a
young woman talking about, um,
crushes on actresses and things.
Actually, you know, it was, it was,
it was really besides the
sometimes walking English
virtually indistinguishable
from what you had read on any kind
of like young millennial focused, um,
social page.
It wasn't a,
none of it was radical or divisive.
It wasn't like,
um,
the way that they got the division
across was they built these tribes where
they're reinforcing in group dynamics.
So you have the LGBT page,
you have a numerous pages
targeting the black community.
That was where they spent most of their
energy. A lot of pages targeting, um,
far right? So, uh, both
old far right, meaning, um,
people who are very concerned about what
does the future of America look like.
And then young, far right,
which was much more angry,
much more like trolling culture.
So they recognize that there's a divide
there that the kinds of memes you're
gonna use to target younger rightwing
audiences are not the same kinds of memes
are going to use to target
older right wing audiences.
So there's a tribe for
older rightwing younger,
right wing and the black community.
There's a baptist tribe,
there's a black liberation tribe,
there's a black women tribe,
there's one for people who
have incarcerated spouses.
There's a brown,
I'm Brown.
Power I believe was the name of it
page. That was very much about, um,
Mexican and Chicano culture.
There was native Americans United.
All these are fake.
All of these are fake.
What are they trying to do with all these?
So you build up this in group dynamic
and over, and he did this over years.
So this was not a short term thing.
They started these pages and 20, 14, 20,
15 timeframe, most of them. Um,
they started some other ones that
were much more political later.
And we can talk about the election if you
want to, but with this tribal thing, um,
you're building up tribes here saying like
as black women in America, this is, um,
here's posts about things that we care
about. Here's posts about black hair,
here's posts about child rearing,
here's posts about fashion and culture.
And then every now and then there would
be a post that would reinforce like as
black people, we don't do this. And so,
or as LGBT people we don't like this.
And so you're building this report.
So like me and you were
having a conversation,
we're developing a relationship
on this page over time.
And then I say like as this kind
of person, we don't believe this.
So it's a way to subtly influenced
by appealing to an ingroup dynamic or
appealing to like as members
of this tribe, as LGBT people.
Of course we hate Mike
Pence as black people.
Of course we're not going
to vote because you know,
we hate Hillary Clinton because
we hate her husband as, um,
as people who are concerned about the
future of America is Texas assumptionists
you know, so, so everything is
presented as members of this tribe.
We think this as members of this tribe,
we don't think this but a lot.
That's why you see the,
I had a lot of,
the posts were not even political,
they were just sort of affirming
the standards of the tribe. Yes.
So they were kind of setting
up this whole long game. Yep.
And then once they got everybody on
board or how many followers are these,
do these pages have?
So the, there was kind of
a long tail. There were um,
I think 88 pages on Facebook
and 133 Instagram accounts.
And I would say maybe 30 of the Facebook
pages had over a thousand followers,
which is not very many. And then, um,
maybe the top 10 had upwards
of 500,000 followers.
So there's, you know, same way
you run any social campaigns.
Sometimes you have hits,
sometimes you have flops. Right.
And what was interesting with the flops
as you would see them repurpose them so
they would decide, you know, the same way
if you're running a social media agency,
well we've got this audience,
this page isn't doing so well.
It's like rebrand it a little
bit, change it up, try to, um,
try to make it appeal to somebody
else. So you do see this, there is a,
there is,
um,
I got this data set and
I was going through these
Instagram memes and you know,
130, 3000 of them. And I was um,
there was a cluster of
images of Kermit the frog.
I was like, what the hell
is Kermit the frog doing in
here? And so I, so then I go,
so this,
the,
the way the platforms provide the data
is I got like a CSV of the posts and then
I got a folder of the images.
And so in order to like connect the dots,
I had to have the image up on one screen.
And the,
this I'm thinking to the CSP up on the
other screens, it's like a spreadsheet.
Okay. Yeah. And I,
and we turned it into a database that
we could track things a little bit more
easily across the platforms. But, um, so
I have this cost of Kermit the frog memes.
And I go and I look
and I realize that the,
they're attributed to an account
army of Jesus. And I thought, well,
that's interesting. What
did you know? These are,
some of them are really Raunchy is like,
it was like Kermit, Miss Piggy, like,
you know, I mean it was just like,
like stupid, stupid, crappy memes. Um,
attached to army of Jesus and
what the Hell is going on here?
I keep going through it.
Hundreds of Kermit memes and then I
get to a post where they say like, um,
this page is owned by homer Simpson.
Now Kermit went to jail for being like,
I don't know, they made some
like some joke. It was stupid.
And all of a sudden the data set
turns into homer Simpson memes.
So again, like this kind of
Raunchy homer Simpson culture, um,
and again,
it's attributed to army of Jesus.
And then I go through all of this and
realize that they didn't get to actually
making army of Jesus a Jesus focused
page until like 900 posts in.
So the, they just renamed
the account at some point.
It used to be called nuts news.
And then they nuts news was what they
called it when it was the Kermit the frog
meme page. And then it gets repurposed
when they realized Kermit's not doing it.
It's not getting the audience they want
homer Simpson's not getting the audience
or engagement they want.
And then they pivot over to Jesus and
then all of a sudden they start, you know,
the likes and,
and things start pouring in.
So what they're doing is they're actually
like either deliberately or they're
just creating placeholders.
Um,
it's kind of a red flag when a brand
new account that was created yesterday
suddenly starts talking about some highly
politically divisive thing or whatever.
But if you lay the groundwork and
you do it over a period of two years,
then somebody who goes and checks
to see what the account was,
where it came from,
how old it is.